[Music]
Hey
hey everybody welcome back to what's new
in Android I'm Dan Sandler from the
system UI team I'm Chet Haase from the
Android toolkit team and I McGee from I
still don't have a name for my team so
from the Android team and you may
remember us from other talks such as
what's new in Android 2017 what's new in
Android 2016 what soon Android 2015 was
soon Android 2014 not what student row
2013 we don't talk about that we don't
talk about that that was the time that
we had jellybean two years in a row was
brilliant we didn't have to redo the
logo or anything but now what's new in
Android what I like to call the Android
keynote nobody else does but I like to
call it that because this is where we
talk to you about all of the developers
stuff going on in the Android platform
in particular let's talk about Android P
specifically let's talk today about oh
hang on Android api's
[Applause]
at first we'll start with this
regression distribution you saw in the
keynote to introduce the dynamic add
bundles tours demo was pretty clear it's
pretty easy for you all you have to do
is click a different menu when you build
your application and we're going to save
you some space it's going to be faster
and easier to download for your users to
download your app and I'm sure you have
a lot of questions about it so we have a
couple of talks this afternoon at 5 p.m.
and 6 p.m. go there if you want answers
because we don't have them so you're
gonna see a slide a whole lot like this
through the rest of the talk I feel like
the main function we serve in this talk
is to tell you the other talks to go to
we're like the appendix we're like the
index for the rest of the content let's
be more like obsolete like vestigial is
that what it is I don't like to think
about that yeah let's be clear a lot of
people back at work I've done all the
hard work we just get to go on stage and
talk about their hard work so speaking
of that let's talk about Android jetpack
we heard Steph talk about this in the
developer keynotes
this is a set of components as well as
guidance on how to build better Android
applications all of you are familiar
with most of what is in Android jetpack
already what we're doing is adding to it
over time with stuff that's going to
make it even better and we're also
improving it over time one of the major
steps that we're taking is what I like
to think of as a refactor because it's a
refactor my favorite thing about the
support library is how the package names
embed the release number in them so for
example we support things like v4
actually we don't support v4 anymore we
have a min SDK of at least 14 now but
it's in the package name isn't that a
little bit silly so we're doing away
with that we're doing a whole lot of
tedious renaming and we're also
providing tools to make it easier for
you to do the similar refactoring you're
going to need to do in your application
as well as an Android studio everything
is being renamed to something more
appropriate called Android X if you want
to know more about the details of that
the renaming as well as doing more
modular more fine-grained splits to make
sure that you know dragging too much
stuff go to the talk learn what's new in
Android support library also there was
an article that was posted on the
Android developers blog about a half
hour ago check
for more of the details there let's talk
about Android test which is part of this
new a jetpack thing going on Android
test is the 80s L stuff the espresso
stuff that hopefully you are already
using really good ways to test your
application now they provide first-class
Kotlin support as well as more elegant
api's for reducing a lot of the
boilerplate here's a simple example we
used to have a way of asserting which a
was not necessarily obvious in the
parameters you were passing also
in the order of the parameters that you
were passing and then it would give you
an error message that also didn't really
help very much so we have something a
little more sensible now you can assert
that it's actually working on the
visible property and the error message
gives you something more that you can
work with a little bit better go to the
frictionless Android testing talk for
more information about that stuff
jetpack architecture is about the
architecture components that were
announced last year at i/o and then
iterated with feedback from the
community and finally went one dot o in
the fall so we have the release parts of
those which includes all the lifecycle
stuff and the view model stuff as well
as the room the persistent data model
stuff and live data so hopefully you are
using that stuff already at least in
your new applications and what we also
have is recently we released the paging
library for doing asynchronous data
paging into recyclerview that was alpha
then beta because that's how those
things work and now it's 1.0 this week
so please start using that and we also
talked in the developer keynote about a
couple of new things that you should
check out soon work manager is currently
in preview there's going to be a talk
about it it's about job scheduling but
job scheduling in a way where we handle
all the cases back in previous releases
instead of you having to use specific
approaches depending on what version and
Device Lee Iran also navigation it turns
out that up versus back is a hard
problem for applications to solve we are
making that much easier and we're
integrating with the tool to make it
even easier yet so go to all these talks
there's an overview talk as well as
specific talks on navigation control
where and work manager and also a talk
on recyclerview and paging me again
it says your name on this plate
keep building suspense into this thing
what's going to happen next who's he
gonna hand the click or two still mine
still you okay let's talk about battery
this is one of the ongoing efforts in
Android to help the users because it
turns out battery is really important
we're all power users unfortunately we
just keep using the power so what can we
do about it we can create these app
standby buckets we're going to monitor
the usage of applications and see how
actively the user is using it and then
make determinations about how much
access that application has to ongoing
things in the system which are going to
take up more battery we also have
background restrictions that the user
has the ability to kick in in settings
so if an application is behaving badly
let's say holding wakelocks for long
periods of time or waking up constantly
or accessing services way more than they
should when it's not on charger then
we'll note that and and expose that in
settings and then the user can take some
action on that if they deem that
necessary go to the battery session on
Thursday morning to learn more the
details there so one of the things that
we've been focusing on with Android
piece privacy maybe that's what it
stands for so one of the things we've
done is that when your app is in the
background it doesn't have access to the
microphone anymore it doesn't have
access to the camera anymore
and it doesn't have access to the sensor
kind of so you won't be you won't
receive the data from the sensors
automatically you can manually pull from
the sensors and you'll get to batch
update but the best thing that you
should to do if you want to get access
to the sensor data is to keep a
foreground service running instead
so no more microphone no more camera for
you I think I've heard in the past that
some apps were trying to stay alive in
memory by playing a white noise or
keeping the the microphone on don't do
that anymore it's not okay cut lean it's
this little thing we announced last year
so we're busy we want to make it better
for all the Kirkland developers out
there I'm sure there's a lot of you here
today so some of the things we've been
doing the art team has been really busy
with d8 r8 and art itself they've been
looking at the bytecode generated by the
cutting compiler divina lies some of the
bytecode patterns that were different
from the ones generated by the java
programming language compiler and they
develop in optimizing for those patterns
we've also been adding a lot of
knowledge
the annotations to our Java API is both
in the core libraries so lip core and
our support libraries to make it easier
for you to use the platform API so when
you're when you're in Catalan and
finally we launched on github a new
library called Android KTX it's a set of
cutting extensions for existing platform
API and the goal here is to try to take
advantage of some of the Catalan
language features to make existing API
is easier to use they're already easier
to use just by using cotton but with the
extension that gets even better we and I
want to thank the community because
we've received dozens of pull requests
and also bugs and feature requests from
you and we've accepted a bunch of them
so if you have ideas if you have things
that you'd like to see in Android KTX
please go to github and we'll take a
look at your at your PR and this is an
example of the kind of code you can
write with KTX if you want to create a
bitmap you don't have to specify it's a
RGB 8 8 8 8 anymore
you can call apply canvas with a meta
click create the canvas for it becomes
this and at the bottom you can see font
since the destructuring assignments for
a color integer so you don't have to do
any shifting or masking of the the int
into bytes we'll take care of that for
you there is a talk by Jack Wharton on
Thursday at 10:30 a.m. is going to go
through most of the extension it's going
to talk about the philosophy behind the
extensions how we write them what are
the kind of extensions that we that we
want to see in that library what we're
not looking for in that library so
before you do all the work and send a PR
go out in that talk to understand what
we are looking for we already talked
about the Android test stuff that is
part of jetpack earlier that's probably
a better more holistic way to test your
application but if there's a specific
situation in which you find it necessary
or helpful to mock the framework and I
don't mean ridicule it because that
wouldn't be nice then it is possible to
do that in easier ways now in mockito we
are not changing the framework but we're
actually integrating changes into
mockito itself so you can now
mock final methods and soon you should
be able to mark static methods
and check is making that face because it
doesn't understand why that's that is so
interesting to you and system created
objects like activity eventually working
on that internally but it should be on
the way eventually a background text
measurement this is part of a bunch of
smaller changes that we made in the text
area it turns out that measurement is
really expensive so most applications do
text and that we'd bet that the text
operations in your application are some
of the most expensive going on in the UI
thread which can contribute to Jang
wouldn't it be nicer if you could
offload that to a background thread so
that by the time you actually need to
render the text or perform those
operations on the UI thread most of the
hard work was done for you so the
observation is that 80 to 90 percent of
the operations that are necessary for
actually displaying text happen in text
measurement well we've made it possible
much easier to actually perform this as
a background operation so we have a
class called pre computed text and you
can query that and you can say I want
you to pre measure this and then you can
set that text that's spannabis x field
later whenever you want so you do it in
a background threads like this you say
create this thing and then you can set
that on the textview later when you
actually need it should be much faster
magnifier is something that if you're
using the preview releases you might see
if you select some text it pops up this
little bar up above it makes it easier
to manipulate the cursor that's really
great for text but the other cool thing
about it is that it's also available for
your applications for any other use case
so there's an api that allows you to pop
up this magnifier for whatever happens
to be in your view so you can show this
and dismiss it and use it for your stuff
as well so core functionality that we
want in the system user interface but
also useful API is for developers to use
for their own purposes I don't know if
you've worked with your design
department and they've specified
something about text in your UI and okay
well I want this aligns you know this
many dips away from the top and then I
want the baseline on the bottom this
many dips away from the bottom and then
you have this interspersed vertical
alignment stuff going on and then you
sort of puzzle with this for a while and
you basically futz
patting in all kinds of different
configurations to sort of get it to
where they wanted to get it we have
worked with that and created some new
attributes and methods and properties
for you to use that make that much
easier so we allow you to just pass us
the information about the baseline
alignment calculations that you would
like to perform and then we'll futz with
padding on your behalf
SmartLink if I I think of this as being
Lincoln Phi but smarter so we already
have the ability to ask for links in a
block of text and it'll detect things
like phone numbers and addresses but we
also have the ability through machine
learning models and stuff that you've
seen through smart text selection to
detect other entities we can do the same
thing with link of Phi it takes a little
bit potentially longer so you do this
off thread so you would basically
generate the links off thread and then
set it on your text view later using
code similar to this there's a text talk
on Wednesday evening so please go to
that for more details about all of this
as well as more so location now you can
take advantage of a new package Android
that net dot Wi-Fi though that RTT it's
the Wi-Fi round-trip time API
it requires compatible hardware on your
phone it also requires a compatible
access point and it allows you to -
sorry - find the precise location
indoors for the the user's device you
need to request the find location
permission and you don't need to connect
to it to the access point so if you're
building an application that requires
locating the user into inside the big
building you can take advantage of this
pious API in Android P accessibility has
some improvements for navigation through
the app so it's easier for you to
declare these functional blocks makes it
easier for accessible users to
understand how things are being grouped
on the screen there's an important talk
on accessibility right now no that's
tomorrow tomorrow okay so hopefully it's
tomorrow I'm not sure that's correct
it's what it's tomorrow two minutes ago
okay all right it's on YouTube all right
yes it is eventually like now yeah I
think I got the day wrong sorry about
that
it's now if you're in the wrong talk I
invite you
Oh my turn
security new API in android pd unified
biometric dialogue so we deprecated the
fingerprint manager because there are
more ways to authenticate yourself with
your body than just with the fingerprint
could be your eyes could be whatever
else that device manufacturers will
think of next
so now we have a single UI for all
devices and all means of authentication
we also have stronger protections for
private keys and very important in your
application if you're using the API
build with serial it doesn't work
anymore the API is still there but
basically returns bogus data so you
cannot rely on it at all anymore various
changes in Enterprise just a couple of
them that are interesting we made it
easier to work with work profile apps or
different profile apps by having these
different tabs you can associate with
them so they're not all mixed together
be to actually have these whole sections
of the different profiles also you're
allowed to lock packages to a specific
task you could have a launcher with just
a minimum set of a group or a single
application that works in combination
with the ability to have ephemeral users
which now gives you kiosk mode so you
will no longer have experiences like I
had on a recent flight as you can see
from my blurry picture where you see a
movie and you wonder what operating
system is running under that so you
swipe from the bottom of the screen you
see the ICS navigation bar and then you
press on the recent test and you swipe
the movie away and you confuse the heck
out of the system I have to admit that's
what I try every time I'm on the only
plane right base and it works a
surprising number of times this is like
more fun for Android engineers this is
what we do hopefully this is nothing -
the navigation now is OK can I talk now
it's alright
very very very briefly all right let's
talk about actually a lot of the system
UI stuff it typically gets shown at one
of the keynotes that precedes what's new
in Android so you've all seen a lot of
the great stuff that users are getting
I'm going to talk to you about some of
the stuff that as developers you might
be interested in the first one is
display cutouts aka well there are other
names for it these are coming to the
ecosystem all over the place and so as a
developer you need to know where it's
safe to draw and where it isn't when you
get your window in sets on
you window inset something or there you
get a display cutout object which gives
you all kinds of interesting data about
the cutout but you're probably going to
want to use something called window
layout in display cutout mode on your
windows so there's a the basic way which
is I I never want to overlap the cutout
just leave a black bar at the top or the
bottom whatever I'm not all that
interested a little more advanced would
be display cutout mode default which is
if you were already going to clear the
status bar just fine we'll let the app
window draw underneath the cutout is
well so you'll get the nice action bar
color extending through the status bar
and extending underneath that cutout
better still or more advanced still is
short edges cutout mode which means
essentially anytime there's a cut out on
the short edges of the device and we're
in portrait I will just draw underneath
you don't have to do anything special
and in that situation you do need to
look at the display cutout and ask it
for the safe in sets essentially well
okay I'm drawing everywhere but you tell
me what rectangle what single rectangle
of the screen is safest to draw in and
then finally the cosmic version of this
you can do short edges but you can
actually get the bounds of the cutout as
a region so you will get the exact set
of rectangles that are unavailable to
you on the screen so you can display UI
in the corners if the corners are
available or if there's a corner cut out
you can move things out of the way so
that it's visible in the center of the
display this is the most advanced
version of it and you can put the
electrical tape away because you can
actually simulate notches now in
developer options on your device this is
really really exciting slices actually
was what we were calling it internally
and we liked it so much we just kept it
you've seen slices now and a couple of
keynotes is essentially something that
we've discovered and learned about on
system UI and the toolkit over many
years of dealing with remote views for
for app widgets dealing with
notifications essentially the problem of
getting content from your app into some
other place so slices is our new
approach to remote content that you can
actually use to project UI into your own
app or into other apps that support it
it's very structured this is not sort of
here as a canvas or an absolute layout
go nuts with it we give you
a structure to fill out and a whole
bunch of very flexible templates in
which to populate that data with some
display hints so that the receiving end
of the slice a slice host kind of knows
what to do with it
these are interactive these are
updatable this is meant to be something
that holds rich UI
sliders controls live information
possibly videos things that actually
feel like real UI is opposed to a
snapshot of something happening in a
distant process somewhere slices are
addressable by content URI and this is
how they're passed around the system and
how they're passed along to app indexing
to be shown in contacts like search and
then finally slices is entirely inside
the support library it's entirely in
jetpack so it's backwards compatible you
can use slices all the way back to API
19 there's a great talk about slices
tomorrow bright and early building our
interactive results for Google search
come to find out more about how all this
technology works and how you can build
your own related to slices is actions
you can think of these as shortcuts with
parameters ramallah likes to think of
them as visible intents this is
essentially a deep link into your app
with some additional payload it's not
just a link to music it's linked to a
particular album or something like that
and you saw these as well in the keynote
showing up in a predictive space inside
our app launching experience actions you
define in actions XML file that goes
into your apk or app bundle and that's
who can get registered with that
indexing so that search results and
predictive features can show those
actions and there's a talk about this -
Thursday slightly less early in the
morning integrating your Android apps
with the Google assistant notifications
there's a lot of great stuff about
digital wellness and controlling
notifications that you saw in the
keynote and I'm very excited about NP
I'm gonna talk about some of the
developers stuff though that we have in
here we asked users what notifications
are most important to them users love
messages so we focused our energy in
enhancing the messaging style API you
can do inline images now you can do
participant images and attach other
metadata about the participant and we
finally now have UI for smart reply
which we've had on Android wear for
years so when you use remote input dot
set choices those will now appear as
chips right in the notification so you
can respond instant
in the middle of a chat without leaving
the notification shade there's tons of
other stuff as usual I had one other
slide that we added about ten minutes
ago to this deck about notifications and
I'm just gonna let that sit on the
screen for a little while so if you're
doing something in the background the
user still needs to know but Android P
does a much better job of allowing
notifications you may already have
running testify to that background
activity including things like
overlaying Windows so with that talk
about the runtime on supporting one of
the most important things for you as an
Android developer is to understand our
deprecation policy it was announced a
few weeks ago
soon we will require all the
applications to target some of the
newest API levels and we're doing that
to make sure that we can keep the
security level of Android as high as
possible as well as performance and a
lot of other nice things so what does it
mean for you as of August this year new
applications published on the Play Store
will have to target API level 26 and as
of November this year and the update to
an existing application that you publish
on the Play Store will have to target
API 26 and you can expect those numbers
to go up over time if you have a native
code in your application we've been
supporting 32-bit and 64-bit for years
now we will make 64-bit ABI is required
as of August of next year you'll still
be able to ship 32-bit support in your
application but we will ask you to ship
64 bits as well one of the reasons to
ship 64-bit on 64-bit devices is that
you get better performance and much
better code out of it if you want to
know more about the depreciation policy
there is a talk to more after know on
Thursday afternoon and I'm sure you have
a lot of questions for the folks there
I've compatibility if you've tried the
Developer Preview in P you might have
noticed something different if you're
one of those nerdy applications that
uses some of our private API on Android
we have two types of private IP is the
APS that are actually marked private and
then there's the this weird add height
thing that we use in the in our source
code it's a Java doc tag that we process
especially to indicate that this is a
public API force not for you just for us
and we're a bit jealous because a lot of
you were using there
so from now on a lot of the CPS will
trigger warnings in one form or another
it might be too so it may be logs when
you make an illegal call for some of
these API is we need to hear from you
that you need those API is for your
application to keep working sometimes
it's just another site we didn't make
the API public it's just because we
didn't think about it so please go to
this URL and let us know if there's an
API that you think should be made public
we might say yes we might also say no we
have three types of lists I won't go
into too much detail here but basically
if an API falls in the blacklist you
will not be able to call it ever I'm not
sure if we have anything in the
blacklist right now but those will
evolve over time so again let us know
what API is you need this is one of the
important reasons this is why we ship
previews we need you to go out there and
try your applications on the previews
because this is the time to find out
when there's problems that either you
can fix before the real release is out
there or you can let us know if it's a
problem that we need to work on instead
and that's a chat trying to increase his
engagement with this podcast so there's
this podcast called a DVD Android the
wrapper backstage and in the episode 89
they had who did you have in the episode
Brian Carlstrom Brian Kallstrom and they
talked about the compatibility issue and
what it means for you so good listen to
it and you came the release 17 of the
NDK brings a lot of very interesting
things so first of all the neural
network API is that were part of API
level 27 we also have a new shared
memory API if you do a lot of j'ni more
importantly we have finally a send the
address sanitizer to make sure your code
is in scribble all over the memory now
you don't need a really device anymore
to use it and we also have a undefined
behavior sanitizer it can be very
difficult to detect undefined behaviors
in your C or C++ code so now there's a
tool for that
we finally remove support for the
deprecated API so if you still use md5
or MIPS MIPS 32-bit or 64-bit support is
gone you should not be shipping those
anymore in the upcoming release our
release 18 we will remove GCC so the GCC
compiler was deprecated last year now
everything is compiled with clang in the
NDK we we think we gave you enough time
so Jesus is going away so if you're
still using it
now it's maybe you should not be in this
talk you should go fix your code and
finally we added support for the simple
per CPU profiler and we also have
support in the IDE in Android studio for
the for native profiling so you don't
even have to type anything in the
terminal graphics and media the camera
API is getting better and better
we've added a lot of things that we are
using ourselves in the camera in the
camera applications for instance who
give you access to the time stamps of
the optical image stabilization so if
you want to build a kind of
stabilization with built in our video
recording an individual recording part
of the camera application now you can if
you're doing if your app is doing a lot
of selfies and using the displays with
flash you can tell the camera that
you're doing that so you can adapt the
exposure accordingly we have support for
USB cameras I haven't seen any use for
it but I've heard some of you asked
about it so now it's available multi-cap
camera support they are some phones
coming out out there with multiple
cameras in the back or in the front I
suppose and now we can expose them as a
logical camera that contains more than
one stream of data image the color I'm
sure a lot of you have familiar with did
map factory and you should not fond of
that API trust me will not either so
there's a new one called image decoder
it's part of Android P the idea is to
make it only easier to decode images but
also to make it possible to decode
animated images so image decoder can
decode bitmaps which also drawables
including animated image drawables you
think all the animated gifs I don't know
how kids are using them possible I
actually love those now so there are few
concepts that you have to learn when you
when you learn image the Curan we're
going to go through them in an example
so we have the concept of a source we
have the concept of the post processor
and finally the header listener so this
is what the API looks like first you
have to call create source on the image
decoder the source can be an ascetic and
EFL the scripture it can be many
different thing and the goal here is
that once you create a source you can
decode multiple images from the same
source this is particularly useful if
you want to build thumbnails you can
decode the same source once at high
resolution once at lower resolution or
even intermediate resolutions and that
can be done from multiple worker threads
then you can called iko iko decode
bitmap you pass the source and you can
should we pass ahead or listener so
their head early center here we have a
lambda it gives you back the decoder
itself the metadata about the source
about the image and the source and it's
inside the header or listener that you
can set the option so in bitmap factor
you had bitmap factory that options that
you had to pass to decode here you have
to wait for the header listener to be
invoked upon since we should point out
to like that set target size that's kind
of a fundamental difference where the
old bitmap it's up there first and then
oh I see that right there that's that's
a huge difference like before if you
wanted the right target size you needed
to work with what in density as well as
in sample size in density and do a lot
of trickery we didn't know how they
worked either yeah so a lot easier now
yeah usually our answer was figure it
out anyway so now you can just tell us
what size you want the bitmap to be in
and what take care of it finally and you
can also set the post processor so post
processor is a same thing as simple
interface it gives you a canvas so you
can draw on the bitmap right after it's
decoded so you can you know I don't know
a header like the title or submitted
data on it
media we are adding a support in the
platform for the HD a profile of vp9 so
you can play HD of videos in your
applications YouTube was doing it but
they had their own way of decoding
decoding videos if you want a device
that doesn't support a GTR do it the
playback will be in a low dynamic range
instead but on a device that's capable
like a pixel to you will be able to see
the HDR stream in all its glory while
also adding support for the and bear
with me because it's a little bit
confusing a format called
hgih gif it rolls off the tongue the
high efficiency image format so it's
based on HD VC which was also called
h.265 and the filename extension is
commonly hdic
i don't know why they use different
letters but that's what they did so we
have to deal with it so it is a
container and it can store multiple
images so you can use it to store a
single image with higher quality and
higher compression ratios than JPEG for
instance JPEG is a lot easier to say I
like JPEG but you can also saw multiple
images if you want animated images of
short movies this is part of the support
library or I guess jetpack now
and this is not the the this is not part
of the compressed API that you find on
bitmap because it's a container it works
differently so this is what it looks
like you have to create a builder you
have to tell us the path where you want
to output the file you have to give us
an advance the width in the height of
the image and the source of the image
can come from the bitmap it can also
come from a surface so you don't
necessarily have one Sun so if you doing
gyah rendering or if you're doing video
playback you can include that directly
as an image and we'll have to go through
an intermediate bitmap and then when you
call writer the choose you can add
multiple bitmaps in this case we're
adding only one and when you call stuff
we write it out I should point out too
that even though it's spelled hei see
it's pronounced jiff go
what are you still doing here
Volken so this is the slide that I'm
excited about very few will be and I'm
sure you will be super excited about
things like subgroup ups in YC RC B
format more more more seriously anybody
who's building middleware for instance
the Unity engine and you know a few
building games
Volken is a low-level graphics API that
gives you a lot more control over the
GPU so we get higher performance cone
and Vulcan 1.1 adds new capabilities
that were not possible in OpenGL but it
also closes the gap with OpenGL so for
instance to support protected content
will you're not able to playback
protected content invoke and before that
won't lock a lot of things like video
players for instance new networks API is
they are not technically part of P
because we announced I mean they are
part of people to announce them in API
level 27 you might have missed that
it's a C API that's designed for mashing
on it's also a fairly low-level API it's
meant for basically playback of trend
models so things like tensorflow are
built on top of general Network API so
you would use tensorflow to do all the
learning and the neural network ApS can
do basically the inference on device the
interesting thing is that we're also
unlocking the access to the DSP that we
use on pixel too so you can get hardware
accelerated machine learning effectively
on select devices a our core is just so
in the developer keynote
couple months ago we introduced a our
core 1.0 they just announced a our core
1.2
this takes care of tracking things in
the real world
the claim is that you had to write a lot
of OpenGL code and it's not always
pleasant so to make your life easier we
introducing support in the emulator so
when you create an EVD you can specify a
virtual camera stream for the back
camera and you get a full 3d scene it
works in any any view that displays the
camera stream and using the keyboard in
the mouse we can just navigate around
around the UI you even get patterns on
that fake TV screen so you can do image
recognition and pattern tracking that
kind of stuff it's available today
also we have seen forms so they already
talked about it in the Deaf keynote I
won't talk about it too much I will only
say this is what I've been working on
for the past few months so I still don't
have a
because we did that with a dream anyway
that's what I was up to and if you want
to know more about sin form there is a
talk tomorrow afternoon at 5:30 p.m. and
we're going to talk about the underlying
tech and how to use the API and finally
Chrome OS on pixel book you can now run
Linux applications on your Chromebook
and in particular you can run Android
studio I believe there are some
limitations but one of the things you
can do is run your and all the apps as
apps on Chrome OS so you can use Chrome
OS as a full-blown Android development
platform I guess whenever it's available
many many more sessions to that tomorrow
and Thursday with also like you know I
said that earlier there's a lot of folks
back home we've been doing all the hard
work we're just talking about it so
thank you very much to all the
engineering teams and the PM's and the
designers and tech writers everyone who
made this possible we didn't do anything
we're just here to hear you we like to
be happy some of us did even less yes
okay and that's it for today so thank
you very much
trust me with the sandbox office hours
bring your questions yes we have we have
framework office hours there's Android
sandbox running all week we've done our
best to bring as many people from our
teams here to be able to talk to you
about these new features these new API
is as possible because we know you can't
get that anywhere else besides Google
i/o and also there's an overflow session
for our overflow area I can't remember
where it is exactly most of the speakers
from Android sessions will make their
way afterwards so if you can't get your
question answered at the session you
should be able to find them after that
like us there now thank you
[Applause]
you
[Music]